[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Michel el midoro
malgré la pluie qui ne cesse de tomber
la préfecture des ivelines prolonge
l'arrêté concernant les restrictions de
l'usage de l'eau et oui Gabriel et ce
jusqu'au 31 décembre la sécheresse
exceptionnelle de l'hiver 2022 et de
l'été 2023 a entraîné une vidange des
nappes fréatiques la nappe de brevval
par exemple du côté de mant Jolie est
toujours en situation de crise elle
n'arrive pas à se recharger malgré les
dernières averses ainsi la zone centre
desésilin est en situation de crise le
reste du département se trouve lui en
situation de vigilance pour rappel les
habitants qui se trouvent dans la zone
d'alerte maximale ont interdiction
d'arroser leurs pelouses leurs potagers
ou même de remplir leurs piscine je
pense que ça devrait aller en ce moment
on n a pas vraiment besoin Gabriel ouais
effectivement en ce moment ça devrait
aller direction coinière maintenant où
l'implantation d'un pylone est contesté
all il s'agit d'un pylone de 18 m de
hauteur de la société FreeMobile son
objectif assurer une meilleure
couverture réseau cependant le maire de
de la commune Didier Fiser conteste son
implantation car ce dernier se
trouverait à proximité d'une crèche le
maire a également déclaré nous ne nous
opposons pas au projet de FreeMobile
néanmoins par principe de précaution
afin de préserver la qualité paysagère
nous avons refusé le lieu d'implantation
proposé malgré plusieurs discussions
avec la ville l'opérateur ne souhaite
pas revoir l'emplacement de ce pilone
freemobil a donc engagé un recours au
tribunal administratif de Versailles on
poursuit ces informations Michel avec de
la bière mine yvine vous en avez déjà
parl l'année dernière dans les ivines
une brasse se brasse une bière 100 %
artisanale baptisée la petite sœur elle
est située à Sartrouville au sein de
cette brasserie Vanessa Collin la jeune
fille de 20 ans a confectionné une bière
embrée à la carotte et attention
Gabrielle grâce à cette recette elle est
devenue la meilleure apprentie brasseuse
de France était à l'occasion de la 11e
cérémonie des rabelés des jeunes talents
de la gastronomie à retenir également
Michel l'élection du Mister île-defance
ça avait lieu ce weekend et parmi les 14
candidats de zinois originaire de Trapp
et de véisi ville coublé participer
comme Martin Auberger on écoute son
interview au micro de Jessie willin de
nos confrères de radio sensation alors
je vais défendre la santé
mentale de chaque individu je vais
pousser les gens à aller de l'avant à
croire en eux et avoir confiance en eux
donc on va voir ce que ça va donner
c'est finalement remémy Ducro qui a été
sacré le plus beau garçon de la région
mais alors qui est Rémi Ducro Gabriel
c'est un Paris originaire du Nord il
tentait pour la seconde fois d'accéder
au titre régional le jeune homme de 27
ans est gestionnaire d'actif immobilier
pour une grande enseigne française de
bricolage et de décoration on écoute sa
réaction déjà je peux dire que je suis
très fier de représenter notre belle
région l'île- de
France j'espère que je serai à la
hauteur moi la cause que je choisis de
défendre c'est la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire on a encore
beaucoup trop de personnes en France qui
qui subissent ça aujourd'hui en 2023 et
pour moi c'est pas normal euh faut qu'on
arrive à à dépasser ça et à et à aider
tout le monde passionné de natation et
de musculation il a désormais quelques
mois pour se préparer pour l'élection
nationale de Mister France 2024 elle
aura lieu le 17 février à reen mal
maison dans les hautes scènes merci
beaucoup Michel pour toutes ces
informations et si vous aussi vous voyez
une information ou une image qui retient
votre attention n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager avec le hashtag 78 news